[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصادي الليله معكم عبد القادر
عياد في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه وحدات
وتتفاعل اخرى في مناطق مختلفه من العالم
نبداها بهذه الصور
المباشره من العاصمه الايرانيه طهران التي
تعيش على واقع الاتفاق الجديد مع الولايات
المتحده الذي سيفرج بمقتضاه عن اموال
ايرانيه مجمده
ثم الى ميامي عاصمه النيجر وفيها نتابع
هذه الصور حيث تعيش البلاد هناك متراقبه
لخيارات تعامل الايكواس مع الانقلاب
في مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله ايضا
بعد الاعلان عن صفقه الامريكيه ايرانيه
البنك المركزي الايراني يعلن ان الاموال
المجمده لدى صول ستنتقل قريبا الى سته
حسابات ايرانيه في قطر مسؤولون امريكيون
يكشفون ان المفاوضات كانت غير مباشره
بواسطه واستضافه قطر على مدى عامين ونصف
العام ومسؤول الامني ايراني يصف الاتفاق
بالانتصار ويؤكد عدم تقديم تنازلات بموجبه
وخيارات التدخل الصعبه في النيجر اجتماع
المرتقب لقاده اركان المجموعه
وبرلمانها يعقد جلسه انطاليا اليوم تصاعد
الجدل بشان دوري مجلس الامن الدولي
يقول ان التدخل العسكري المحتمل قانوني
دون الحاجه لموافقه مجلس الامن الاتحاد
الاوروبي يقول انه سيدعم اي اجراء
للمجموعه ووفد وساطه يضم رجال الدين من
نيجيريا في ميامي
مزيد من الهجمات في منطقه البحر الاسود
بعد اعلان وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اسقاط 20
صاروخا اوكرانيا السلطات المواليه لموسكو
تقول انها اسقطت مزيدا من الصواريخ
والمسيارات الاوكرانيه
تعلن ما تسميه بموسم تفجيرات القرم حتى
تحريرها وموسكو تتوعد بالرد
الجيش السوداني يقصف مواقع للدعم السريع
في الخرطوم وام درمان والدعم يطلق مضادات
ارضيه قتلى وجرحى في دارفور باشتباكات
مستمره في مناطق مختلفه في نيالا وعلى وقع
مناشدات الامميه استمرار المعارك يهدد
بنفاذ الادويه
في لقائنا اليومي على منصاتنا الرقميه كنا
قد ناقشنا اخبار غرق مزيد من القوارب التي
تحمل طالبي لجوء في مياه البحر الابيض
المتوسط حيث قالت السلطات الفرنسيه ان سته
اشخاص لقوا مصرعهم في غرق قاربهم اما في
تونس فقد تم الاعلان عن انقاذ 13 شخصا بعد
غرق مركز كان يقلهم في سواحل محافظه قابس
لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد
طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي كيف يمكن ايقاف
ماسي غرق قوارب طالبي اللجوء في البحر
الابيض المتوسط وقد جاءت النتائج على
النحو التالي 80 في المئه قالوا انهم مع
خيار دعم التنميه في بلدان طالبي اللجوء
بينما صوت نحو 9% لصالح خيار مكافحه
التهريب بشكل صارم واخيرا قال نحو 11%
انهم مع تكثيف دوريات الانقاذ
الدوليه
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه ولقاؤنا
على المنصات الرقميه
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده عربيا
ومتفاعله دوليه
[موسيقى]
قالت شبكه الاتفاق الذي توصل اليه
الايرانيون والامريكيون في الدوحه بشان
تبادل السجناء والافراج عن اموال ايرانيه
مجمده كان ثمره عمليه طويله وصعبه وقدمت
الشبكه بعد التفاصيل المتعلقه بهذا
الاتفاق من جهته قال محمد رضا فرزين رئيس
البنك المركزي الايراني ان الاموال
الايرانيه ستوضع في سته حسابات ايرانيه
بدوله قطر
لم تكن المفاوضات الامريكيه الايرانيه
يوما سهله في العاصمه القطريه الدوحه اجلت
الطرفان مفاوضات غير مباشره في عمليه
استمرت سنتين ونصف السنه لم يلتق
الامريكيون والايرانيون خلال كل هذه المده
لان العلاقات الدبلوماسيه مقطوعه بين
الطرفين لعب القطريون دور الوسيط والمسهل
وتنقلوا بين الطرفين في عمليه مكوكيه وحسب
شبكه سان ان كان المسار شائكا وتطلب جهدا
اللوجسيا للحفاظ على السريه التي تحتاجها
مفاوضات بهذه الاهميه شارك في هذه
المفاوضات من الجانب الامريكي وزاره
الخارجيه والبيت الابيض ووزاره الخزانه
التي زادت المفاوضات صعوبه لحرصها على
التاكد من ان اي اتفاق سيحافظ على رقابه
صارمه على الاموال الايرانيه حسب سي ان ال
قبل سته اشهر بدات تتبلور ملامح الاتفاق
الذي يتضمن تبادلا للاسرى وافراجا عن
اموال مجمده في الخارج تقول ان الامريكيين
حصلوا على معلومات ملموسه يوم تاسع اغسطس
الحالي تؤكد الافراج عن اربعه السجناء
امريكيين في اليوم التالي ونقلهم للاقامه
الجبريه مع العلم ان السجين الخامس كان في
الاقامه الجبريه من قبل في الجانب المالي
من الاتفاق ستنقل سته مليارات دولار من
اموال ايرانيه مجمده في كوريا الجنوبيه
الى سويسرا ومن سويسرا الى دوله قطر يتوقع
ان تتطلب عمليه نقل الاموال وقتا يراوح
بين الثلاثين وخمسه واربعين يوما وحسب سان
ان سيصبح وصول الايرانيين الى هذه الاموال
اسهل في قطر اما رئيس البنك المركزي
الايراني فقد اوضح ان الاموال ستودع في
سته حسابات ايرانيه في دوله قطر وان هذه
الاموال ستستخدم لشراء السلع التي لا تخضع
للعقوبات
وكشف مصدر امني ايراني لوكاله فارس ان
تبادل السجناء كان ملحقا غير مكتوب في
الاتفاق النووي لعام 2015 بطلب من
الامريكيين اذا رغم صعوبه المسار يتوصل
الامريكيون والايرانيون الى اتفاق بوساطه
قطريه ما يحل الامل في امكانيه تحقيق
انجاز مماثل بشان الاتفاق النووي
[موسيقى]
من واشنطن معنا الدكتور ايرلانتوني وين
مساعد وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه السابق ومن
طهران محمد صالح صدقيان باحث مختص في
القضايا الاقليميه اهلا بكم ابدى مع السيد
محمد صالح صدقيان عامان ونصف من التفاوض
اثمر في النهايه الاتفاق على هذه الصفقه
باعتقادك ما الذي جرى حتى انهى هذا المسار
الطويل من التفاوض الجانب يقول بانه لم
يتنازل وبالتالي ما الذي حدث باعتقادك
والى ضيفك وللمشاهدين اني اعتقد بان هذه
المفاوضات التي دامت هذه الاشهر الكثيره
وكانت اشهر صعبه وطويله ايضا هذه
المفاوضات كانت في سلطنه عمان في مسقط في
ابوظبي في قطر وبالتالي هناك اكثر من جهه
ساهمت في انجاح او التوصل الى هذه الصفقه
التي تمت حاليا
وان يعتقد بان هذه الصفقه مهمه جدا في
الجانب الايراني الشارع الايراني متفائل
جدا
لعقد هذه الصفقه ويامل ان تنجز هذه الصفقه
بسلاسه ان تحقق اهدافها وبالتالي هم
يتطلعون كما قالت المصادر الى مرحله ما
بعد هذه الصفقه وبالتالي انا اعتقد بان
الايرانيون يعني عملوا بجد وبمسؤوليه
متناهيه من اجل التو صل الى عقد هذه
الصفقه الجانب الامريكي ايضا عمل بهذا
الاتجاه ولا ننسى الدوري الكبير الذي لعبه
لعبته الوساطه القطريه والوساطه العمانيه
من اجل انجاز هذه طيب ايضا على هذه
الدكتور
اويم هل يمكن اعتبار هذه الصفقه اختراق في
هذا الجدار الموصد في العلاقه بين واشنطن
وطهران
بالتاكيد انا اعتقد يمكن نعتبر هذه الصفقه
خطوه جيده بعد فتره طويله من
الخطوات الفاشله في السابق تطلب الامر
جهدا كبيرا من
قبل الذين جمعوا الطرفين سويا وبالتالي ان
هذا امر مرحب به بالنسبه لكل افراد الذي
سيجد تبادلهم السجنه السجناء وعلينا ان
ننتظر ماذا ستكون نتيجه ولكن بالتاكيد هذا
مؤشر جيد جدا بان هناك امكانيه للتعاون
بين البلدين رغم من ان هناك بعض القضايا
الصعبه جدا بينهما ما المقصود بقولك ننتظر
النتيجه فيما يتعلق بنتائج هذه الصفقه او
ما يمكن ان يبنى على هذه الصفقه في مختلف
الملفات دكتور وين
اعتقد اولا علينا ان نؤكد بان التطبيق او
تنفيذ هذه الصفقه هناك التقارير وكل
المسؤولين يقولون ان الامر تتطلب سته الى
ثمانيه اسابيع اخرى قبل قبل نقل الاموال
والى ان
يطلق صراحه الاشخاص السجناء
والمهم هو
التطبيق وبعد ذلك علينا ان ننظر ننتظر
لنرى هل هناك امكانات اخرى قد تتحقق بشكل
متوازي في حول مواضيع اخرى صعبه جدا
الموجوده بين ايران ولايات المتحده وذلك
يشمل
الاجراءات والترتيبات الامنيه التي هي
معلقه منذ فتره من الزمن وزمل ايضا مواضيع
امن واستدعمت السفن والبحريه في منطقه
ويشمل ذلك
ما شاهدناه من هجمات على قوات الامريكيه
في الشرق الاوسط اذا هناك عدد من القضايا
ومشاكل او الخلافات التي
قد تكون قائمه تحتاج الى حل ونامل ان سنرى
نشهد عمليه
ايجابيه وتقدم ونعمل ذلك
مناقشات حول تجهيزات ايران للاسلحه الى
روسيا
هذه الملفات دكتور هنا اسال ضيفي الدكتور
محمد صلاح ضيفي من طغران هذه الوساطه كانت
برعايه ومتابعه دول الاقليميه سلطنه عمان
ومؤخرا دوله قطر وما قامت به وبالتالي الى
اي مدى مهم لهذه الدول الاقليميه ان تكون
اطار لبحث ملفات الاخرى غير ما يتعلق
بمساله هذه الصفقه
ان يعتقد بان هذا شيء مهم جدا وعندما تقوم
قطر وسلطنه عمان بمثل هذه الوساطه
بالتاكيد هم يشعرون ايضا بان التوصل لاي
اتفاق بين طهران وواشنطن هو ينعكس بشكل
ايجابي على على الامن والاستقرار في هذه
المنطقه كلنا يعلم بان الولايات المتحده
اقامه مؤخرا بجلب طائرات تجهيزات عسكريه
طائرات 16 اف 35 بارجه قوات المارينز مزيد
من الجنود الامريكيين وبالتالي هذا
التصعيد لا يخدم الامن والاستقرار في هذه
المنطقه لا يخدم الدول في هذه المنطقه
ايضا
وبالتالي هم
يشعرون بان اي تقارب او اي تنفيذ لاي
تفاهمات معينه بين طهران واشنطن تنعكس على
على الوضع وضع العام في هذه المنطقه
وبالتالي انا اعتقد بان مثل هذه خطوه وان
كانت غير مهمه باعتقادي لان الافراج عن
سته مليارات او سبعه مليارات من الوداع
الايرانيه المحتجزه في كوريا الجنوبيه
ربما لا تستطيع ان تفعل شيء في هذا
الاقتصاد الايراني الذي يعاني من عقوبات
اقتصاديه منذ اكثر من من عشر سنوات
وبالتالي ان يعتقد بان مثل هذه الاموال هي
اموال ضئيله لهذا الاقتصاد الايراني
الكبير والنامي لكن البدء بمثل هذه الخطوه
خطوه في غايه شكرا من اجل التوصل الى
التفاهمات مستقبليه مطار محمد صالح صدقيان
ان الباحث المختص في القضايا الاقليميه
وكذلك الشكر
لضيفي من واشنطن الدكتور ايري الانطوني
وين مساعد وزير الخارجيه الامريكي السابق
هذا وقال السفير الايراني في الدوحه حميد
دهقان ان ثمانيه وفود ايرانيه وصلت وغادرت
مطار الدوحه خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين وقد
جاء كلام دهقاني في معرض تعقيبه على لقاء
جمعه مع وزير الخارجيه للشؤون السياسيه
الايراني علي باقر في مطار الدوحه
قولهم انه في حين ان كوريا الجنوبيه تعمل
على تحويل الاموال الا انها تشعر بالقلق
من ان تحويل سته الى سبعه او سبعه مليارات
دولار من عملتها الى عملات اخرى في وقت
واحد وترى ان ذلك سيؤثر سلبا على سعر
الصرف وعلى اقتصادها وهذا ما يدفعها للسير
ببطء في العمليه بتحويل مبالغ صغيره من
الاصول المجمده وحسب المسؤولين الامريكيين
على كوريا الجنوبيه ايضا تجنب استخدام
النظام المالي الامريكي اثناء عمليه تحويل
الاموال لان ذلك قد يعرضها لعقوبات
امريكيه ولهذا السبب تم ترتيب سلسله معقده
من التحويلات تستغرق وقتا طويلا من خلال
بنوك دوله ثالثه لم يعلن عنها
هاجم مكتب رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
والاتفاق الامريكي الايراني وقال ان موقف
اسرائيل معروف ومفاده ان الترتيبات التي
لا تفكك البنى التحتيه النووي الايرانيه
ولا توقف برنامجها النووي وتقدم الاموال
للطهران تذهب في خدمه ما سماه الارهاب
الذي ترعاه ايران
نقلت وكاله عن متحدث باسم الاسطول
الامريكيه الخامس في الخليج قوله ان قوات
بحريه غربيه طالبت السفن التي تعبر مضيق
هرمز بالابتعاد عن مياه ايران الاقليميه
كما نقلت الوكاله عن المتحدث باسم الاسطول
الامريكي الخامس ان التحذير الغربي للسفن
الماره عبر مضيق هرمز جاء لتجنب استيلاء
ايران عليها
نددت جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين بما سمته
الوجود الامريكي المكثف قباله السواحل
اليمنيه وباب المندب وقالت الجماعه في
بيان صادر عن اجتماع مجلس الوزراء التابعي
لها ان قواتها البحريه جاهزه للتعامل مع
امام ما يمس سياده اليمنيه وينافي
القوانين والاعراف الدوليه بحسب ما جاء في
البيان
[موسيقى]
الى اخر تطورات الانقلاب في النيجر حيث
قرر برلمان مجموعه ايكواس ارسال لجنه الى
نيامي لمقابله قاده الانقلاب وبحث سبل
انهاء الازمه دبلوماسيا وياتي ذلك بعد
تعذر عقد اجتماع او اجتماعيه لمهمين
احدهما لمجلس الامن والسلم الافريقي
والثاني لقاده جيوش اكواس في غانا بشان
خيار ارسال قوات عسكريه لاعاده النظام
الدستوري في النيجر وفي خضم الجدل الدائر
بشان الاليات القانونيه للتدخل اكواس
عسكريا قال مفوض الامن والسلم في المجموعه
ان القيام بعمل عسكري لا يحتاج اذنا من
مجلس الامن الدولي
الفنيه كما اعلن ولكن عندما يحدث في زمن
انقسام وتخبط داخل البيت الافريقي بشان
النيجر في الحقيقه قد تكون غير ذلك تماما
في يوم واحد تعذر عقد اجتماعين مهمين لبحث
خيارات مواجهه اخر انقلاب في المنطقه
الاجتماع الاول لمجلس الامن والسلم
الافريقي بشان تعليق عضويه النيجر في
الاتحاد الافريقي والثاني الذي كانت
العيون اليه مشدوده هو لقاء قاده جيوش
اكواس كان مقررا السبت في العاصمه الغنيه
اكرا لبحث التدخل العسكري من اجل اعاده
النظام الدستوري في بلد يحكمه العسكر منذ
السادس والعشرين من يوليو الماضي تفعيل
القوه الاحتياطيه لمجموعه غرب افريقيا كما
اوصت القمه الاخيره في ابوجا اثارت المزيد
من الاسئله بشان خيار التدخل العسكري
والياته القانونيه بل وحتى احتمال حدوثه
في منطقه عدوى لانقلابات والحروب فيها
اخطر من كل الماريوهات المسبقه قرروا
اكواس ارسال قوه عسكريه الى بلد عضو في
المجموعه ليس بيدها فقط استنادا لمثاق
الامم المتحده الفصل الثامن المرتبط
بالتنظيمات الاقليميه تنص الماده الثالثه
والخمسون على ان مجلس الامن يستخدم تلك
التنظيمات والوكالات الاقليميه في اعمال
القمع كلما راى ذلك ملائما ويكون عملها
حينئذ تحت مراقبته واشرافه اما التنظيمات
والوكالات نفسها فانه لا يجوز بمقتضاها او
على يدها القيام باي عمل من اعمال القمع
بغير اذن المجلس بدا ان مفوض الامن والسلم
في اكواس اكد في احدث تصريحاته ان
المجموعه لديها اسس قانونيه للتدخل في
النيجر ولا تحتاج الى اذن من مجلس الامن
الدول الموقعه على بروتوكولات ايكواس
المتعلقه بمنع الصراعات وحفظ السلام
والامن وعلى هذا الاساس القانوني كنا قد
تدخلنا في ليبيريا وسيراليون ولم ناخذ
موافقه من مجلس الامن الدولي وابلغناهم
بعد التدخل ولم يكن هذا خرقا والاساس
القانوني الثاني هو طلب محمد بازوم وهو
الرئيس الشرعي للنيجر المساعده منا
لتحريره لانه بات رهينه ومجلس الامن
الدولي منقسم ولا توجد طريقه للذهاب اليه
انقلاب النيجر قلب حسابات اكواس ووضعها في
مازق وامام امتحان قد يكون الاصعب منذ
نشاتها من منظمه اقتصاديه في البدايات الى
هيئه لفض النزاعات في القاره وقد نجحت في
تحقيق ذلك في بعض الدول مثل سيراليون
وغينيا بيساو وسحل العاج ومالي اليوم لا
تعرف الامكانيات الحقيقيه للتكتل من اجل
استخدامه القوه العسكريه لازاحه قاده
انقلاب في قاره الاستثناء فيها عدم استلاء
العسكر على الحكم القبول بالانقلاب يثير
مخاوف استمرار سقوط احجار الدومينو في
منطقه
تتسارع فيها وعليها القوى الكبرى تحت
مسميات مختلفه رفضه بتدخل عسكري يزيد
الخشيه ايضا من امتداد الصراع الى اكثر من
دوله وتورط اكثر من طرف اقليمي وخارجي
بشكل مباشر وغير مباشر خي ارات ايكواس
وحتى اللحظه كلها مره
ولد الشيخ سيداتي الخبير في الشؤون
الافريقيه هل لديك سيد الهبه ولد الشيخ
باعتقادك وبما ترجح هذا التاجيل لاستماع
قاده الجيوش على مستوى ايكواس ليس ذلك فقط
وكذلك تاجيل اجتماع لمجلس الامن على مستوى
الاتحاد الافريقي
مرحبا واهلا بدا الانقسام الحاصل في
المنظمات الدوليه والاقليميه حول التدخل
العسكري يظهر للعلن واضح ان موقف الجزائر
وحلفائها في الاتحاد الافريقي ضد التدخل
بدا يؤتي اكله في القاره الافريقيه ايضا
المجلس الامن الذي كان مستشار في السابق
في عمليات التدخل العسكري اتضح ايضا انه
غير غير موجود الان لا يمكن ان يلجا اليه
في ظل فيتو صيني وروسي مرتقب ايضا فرنسا
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه اتضح خلال
اليومين الاخيرين ان اجندتهما غير موحده
في النيجر الاعلان السريع لفرنسا عن وجود
اجتماعي اليوم لقاده الاركان صاحبه اعلان
من الاعلام الامريكي من مسؤول امريكي ان
الاجتماع سيكون مؤجلا وفعلا تاجل الاجتماع
الى الاسبوع القادم حسب
ما هو معلن وما هو معروف اذا هناك ارتباك
في الموضوع واضح في التعاطيم مع تدخل
العسكري وهناك انقسام واضح وبين عليه ما
الذي قد يضيفه هذا الموقف الجديد المعلم
من قبل روسيا وتحذيرها من اي عمل عسكري
كما قال البيان الروسي بانه سيدخل كل هذه
المنطقه منطقه الساحل في توترات خطيره
وخطيره جدا ما الذي قد يضيفه هذا التصريح
الروسي لهذا المشهد
يزيد المشهد تعقيدا فالغرب لا يريد روسيا
طرفا جديدا في النيجر لا يريد النيجر
اوكرانيا في غرب افريقيا لا يريد معركه
جديده في هذه المنطقه اعلان الروس بهذه
المستوى دليل على ان سيله اتفاقيات عسكريه
كما حصل مع مالي ومع بوركينا فاسو للدفاع
المشترك مع روسيا وبالتالي حمايه
الانقلابيين من طرف روسيا قاتلات الروسيه
هذا واضح ومعروف هذه نفس المسيره نفس
الخطوات شبرا بشبر لما حصل مع انقلاب
مالي وبوركينا فاسو انقلابيون يبداون
بمشاكل مع المنظومه
ثم عظمه ثم تخرج روسيا على الخط ثم تتعقد
الامور ويستتب بالامر للانقلابيين في كل
يوم يكسب هؤلاء الانقلابيون ويبتعد التدخل
العسكري عن
فعاليته وعلى حتى امكانيته
الاخير او تعليقات وتصريحات الاخيره فيها
يعني بعض النقاط قد تبدو جديده وكان هناك
مغازله لقاده الجيش بانهم لم يساندوا
الانقلاب الا للحفاظ على الدماغ وانه لن
تكون هناك حرب في النيجر وانما ما يمكن
تسميته بعمليات
جراحيا ماذا عن هذه التصريحات
لكاس من اول يوم تعرفه صعوبه التدخل
العسكري تعرف انها منقسمه دولها منقسمه
على هذا الخيار غير متفقا تعرفون صعوبه
الصعوباته حتى في دول الاكثر حماسا الدوله
المجاوره
نيجيريا كان مجلس شيوخها اعلن رفضه لهذه
التدخل هناك انقسام على التدخل ايضا دفعت
قرارات
دفعت الجيش للتوحد دفعت حتى الشعب للتوحد
اصبح هناك
حمايه وطنيه
لانقلابيين من اي تدخل واعتداء خارج نجاح
الانقلاب في تسويق هذا وفي شده الاكواس
باقناع بعض القوى المحليه والداخليه بتبني
خياراتها حتى الان الخيارات محدوده الرئيس
المحتجز شكرا حزبه اغلبهم محتاجون
شكرا لك واعتذر منك ادركنا الوقت من
نواكشوط الهيبه ولد الشيخ سيداتي الخبير
في الشؤون الافريقيه
هذا وجدد الاتحاد الاوروبي ادانته الشديده
للانقلاب في النيجر ورحب الاتحاد بقرارات
ايكواس خلال القمه الاستثنائيه وايد
الاتحاد جهود هذه المنظمه واعلن استعداده
لدعمها مجددا مجددا دعوته الى العوده الى
النظام الدستوري في النيجر
هذا ويخشى المواطلون في النيجر من ان
يفاقم التدخل العسكري والمحتمل لدول
مجموعه ايكواس من الاوضاع الاقتصاديه
والامنيه التي يعيشونها
الحل العسكري المحتمل للازمه في النيجر هو
حديث الساعه لدى الكثير من الناس
مع نذر تدخل عسكري من دول في منظمه
الاكواس في اعاده الرئيس المحتجز الى
السلطه لكنه حديث لا يخلو ايضا من تناول
ثروات البلاد وطرق استغلالها
ليس من الطبيعي ان يتذيل بلد مثل النيجر
قائمه الدول الفقيره فهو رابع اكبر منتج
لليورانيوم في العالم ولديه الذهب في
الوقت الذي توجد فيه بلدان ليست لديها
مصادر مثلنا ومستواهم المعيشي افضل منا
المشكله ليست في الثروات ولكن في طريقه
تسييرها
اخرون فضلوا الصلاه والدعاء لتجنيب بلادهم
الاسوا
وسط تدمر مما يعتبرونه تدخلًا في شؤونهم
الداخليه
بعضهم يعاقبون النيجر
خوفا من فرنسا
وعدوهم
يقاربون ويفرضون العقوبه على جمهوريه
النيجر
كما لما في ايدي الفرنسيين
اما محمد فيراقب عن كثب الاوضاع في البلد
لم يتوقف عمله بسبب الازمه وان تراجع دخله
يتقاسم مع الركاب همومهم من ضعف القدره
الشرائيه وارتفاع الاسعار والانقطاعات
المتكرره للكهرباء والهواجس المتعلقه
بالمستقبل
حقا لم يعد العمل كما كان تغير الوضع
كثيرا عندما تحصل على البنزين قد تجد
زبونا واحدا او اثنين الان الامور ليست
على ما يرام
تكمن العقده في النيجر في صعوبه حل الازمه
مع وجود رئيس محتجز تطالب المجموعه
الدوليه باعادته الى السلطه ومجلس عسكري
يقول ان تلك الصفحه قد طويت نهائيا
بعد مرور اكثر من اسبوعين على الانقلاب
تبدو الحياه طبيعيه في شوارع النيجر لكن
تبقى المخاوف والهواجس من اي تدخل عسكري
محتمل وما سينتج عنه من تداعيات حاضره
بقوه
سنغتربيه الجزيره ميامي
[موسيقى]
مره اخرى مسرح لهجمات مره واخرى بثلاثه
صواريخ قالت الدفاع الروسيه انها من طراز
اس 200 الخارجيه الروسيه قالت ان الهجوم
لا يمر دون رد بينما قالت قياده الجنوب في
الجيش الاوكراني ان موسم التفجيرات في
القرن سيستمر التطورات في القرن تزامنت مع
معارك وعمليات قصف متبادل في دونيتس
وزابولوجيا وانطلاق تدريبات لقوات اسطول
الشمال في الجيش الروسي
شبه جزيره القرم في صداره المشهد في
اوكرانيا مره اخرى باعلان سلطاتها
المواليه لروسيا اسقط صواريخ في مضيق
الكرش مع نفي وقوع اي اضرار بجسر القرن
تعلن الدفاع الروسيه محاوله اوكرانيه لشن
الهجوم على الجسر بصواريخ اس 200
واعتراضها وتحدثت مصادر الروسيه عن كونها
الصواريخ معدله لتصبح هجوميه بينما اشارت
سلطات القرمل لروسيا الى ان الاجهزه
الامنيه الروسيه قامت بتشكيل ستار دخاني
على جسر القرم المسيرات عنوان المرحله
ايضا اذ تعرضت شبه جزيره القرم وفق دفاع
الروسيه لهجمات بطائره مسيره اوكرانيه
وكان الامر نفسه في مقاطعتي
الروسيتين
المتحدثه باسم قياده عمليات الجنوب في
الجيش الاوكراني قالت ان موسم التفجيرات
في القرن سيستمر
لقد اشار الجيش الى ان موسم التفجيرات في
القرن سيستمر بالفعل وستظل شبه جزيره
القرم مضطربه حتى تحريرها اما الخارجيه
الروسيه فوصفت الهجمات على جسر القرن
بالارهابيه وقالت انها لن تفقدون رد لكن
كيف قطعت هذه الصواريخ مسافات طويله وصولا
الى هناك تساؤل ياتي بينما يقرا محللون ما
يحدث في كونه استراتيجيه اوكرانيه تعتمد
مبدا الرضع والضغط مقابل الضغط تنشر
الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه في ظل الحرب
الاعلاميه على صفحتها على التيليجرام
فيديو لمسيره مائيه وعمليه هجوميه وتقول
دون تفاصيل انها لتدمير من سمتهم غزاه
موسكو على الارض وفي الهواء وفي الماء
لكنك تقر بالمقابل بالتعرض مناطق عديده في
البلاد لاكثر من ثلاث نهاره روسيه وقصف
مكثف خلال ساعات بصواريخ مجنحه على الجهه
الاخرى تعلن الدفاع الروسيه
دفعه الجويه من تدمير نحو 30 مسيره
واستهداف تمركز القوات والمعدات
الاوكرانيه في اكثر من 100 منطقه تتحدث
موسكو عن ضربه باسلحه جويه عاليه الدقه
بعيده المدى على مطار عسكري بالقرب من
كولومبيا في منطقه
وضربها مقر القياده الاماميه للفيلق
العاشر للقوات الاوكرانيه بالقرب من مدينه
اوريخوفا بمنطقه زابولوجيا اما الاركان
الاوكرانيه فتقول ان قوتها مستمره في
الهجوم على محوري
وانها صدت هجمات روسيه في مقاطعه
معطيات الحرب تبدو رياحها لا تجري كما
خططت له القياده الاوكرانيه
اعلن اقاله رؤساء مراكز التجنيد العسكري
في عموم البلاد فنظام التجنيد يجب ان يدار
من قبل اشخاص يعرفون جيدا ما هي الحرب حسب
تعبيره والحرب لا تبدو محصوره مع
امتداداتها الجغرافيه وتداعياتها ورسائلها
فتدريبات لقوه اسطول الشمال في الجيش
الروسي انطلقت وفق الدفاع الروسيه يشارك
فيها اكثر من ثمانيه الاف جندي وعشرين
سفينه حربيه اضافه الى غواصات وسفن دعم
معنى من جنائب العقيده الكسندر رئيس تحرير
المجله العسكريه السويسريه باعتقادك
التركيز مره اخرى على شبه جزيره القرم ما
الحسابات العسكريه هذه المره
نعم
ان هذا الجسر يعتبر خط تقاطع مهم جدا
للامدادات وهو ايضا يؤدي الى القواعد
الموجوده في الجنوب وهو ايضا يعتبر
تجمع
لقواعد العسكريه
ومقرات القيادات ووحدات البحريه كلها تاتي
من هذه المنطقه كيف تقول انه موسم
التفجيرات حتى تحرير شبه جزيره القرم هل
يبدو هذا الهدف واقعيين امام هناك حسابات
اخرى
ان استعاده شبه جزيره القرم سيكون
عمليه طويله جدا ومكلفه للغايه ولكن
بالتاكيد ذلك يضعف القوات والبنى
الارتكازيه في
شبه الجزيره امر مهم
لتحقيق النصر في هذه المواجهه في جنوب
اوكرانيا هل للاسلحه التي تم بها دعم
اوكرانيا
عامل مهم في الوصول وتنفيذ هذه الاهداف في
شبه جزيره القرم
دور مهم للغايه لان
الدفاعات الجويه الروسيه واوكرانيا قويه
جدا ومكثفه جدا وبالتالي فقط الاسلحه
الروبوتيه او المسيرات يمكن ان تجتاز هذه
الدفاعات الجويه بسبب حجمها الصغير
قدرته على الاخفاء من جنائب العقيده رئيس
تحرير المجله العسكريه السويسريه شكرا
جزيلا لك
اعلن وزير الدفاع البولندي ماريوس بوشاشتك
انشاء فرقه عمل عسكريه بالقرب من الحدود
مع بيلاروسيا لهدف تدريب الجيش البولندي
في مقاطعه
وقال الوزير خلال زياره للمنطقه الحدوديه
مع بيلاروسيا ان الهدف من الفرقه هو
الدفاع عن الحدود في حاله تدهور الوضع وفق
تعبيره
من
مدير مجلس حوار مسك للعلاقات الدوليه
ومنكي الخبير البولندي في الشؤون الدوليه
وابدا معك ضيف من كييف السيد لوكاش
ادامسكي كيف تصف الوضع حاليا بين روسيا
بين بيلاروسيا من جهه
وبولندا كيف تصفه في هذه المرحله
الوضع حاليا هو وضع صعب لكنه كان صعبا
حقيقه على مدى نحو 30 عاما
وخاصه في اعقاب
2020 بعد الانتخابات الرئاسيه حيث الكثير
من
الاحزاب المعارضه وافراد المجتمع تم
اعتقالهم وحبسهم الان في هولندا تعتبر
بيلاروسيا مشاركه في العدوان الروسي على
اوكرانيا انا الان في كير لكنني بولندي
نرى اننا الى حد كبير
مصالح الديلاروسيا تختلف عن المصالح
الروسيه رغم ان
هو نظام استبدادي
من وجهه نظري المصلحه الامن القومي
الفنلندي نحن نرى ان هناك فرقا في المصالح
بين مصالح روسيا ومصالح
بيلاروسيا
الان الوضع تجارب طبعا بين بيلاروسيا وبين
بولندا وحتى دول حلفا الاطلسي تجاوز
الموضوع مساله التصريحات الى تحركات
عسكريه واستعدادات وتدريب الى غير ذلك
وبالتالي كيف ستتعامل منسك مع هذه
التطورات وهذه الاتهامات
نعم في الحقيقه هناك
تفاقم في الوضع وهو مستمر منذ فتره وواضح
ان التحركات التصعيديه لها علاقه
في هولندا ومنذ الانتخابات او منذ
الانتخابات التي ستحدث وهي لها علاقه بهذا
التصعيد هنا في بيلاروسيا المسؤولون
يراقبون الوضع منذ فتره من الزمان وبدا
الوضع منذ فرض العقوبات التي فرضها الغرب
اوروبا الغربيه
وطولندا فرضتها من جانب واحد وما زال هناك
انا سعيد ان يقال انه كما يقول الضيف هناك
فرق في المصالح بين روسيا وبيلاروسيا
للحكومته تفعل كل شيء لدفع بيلاروسيا الى
احضانه روسيا وحشرها في هذه الزاويه لهذا
السبب الامور تجاوزت
التصريحات الى بعض التحركات العسكريه لهذا
السبب بيلاروسيا قررت امتلاك الاسلحه
النوويه كنوع من الرضع ولكي نعمل ان لا
يتحول الامر
هل من مصلحه بولندا ومن ثم الدول الحلف
الاطلسي ان تضع
بيلاروسيا في هذه الوضعيه والتي كان
ختامها اعاده انتشار الاسلحه النوويه في
هذا البلد
دعنا نبدا ببعض الحقائق الاساسيه
اولا هناك على الاقل
الف معتقل سياسي في بيلاروسيا وايضا قاده
المجتمع من الفالنديين معتقلون ايضا هناك
جارتان لبولندا وهما روسيا وبيلاروسيا
هاجمتها من دون مبررات اوكرانيا
في بولندا نتذكر ما حصل قبل نحو عامين
وايضا النظام الذي يدافع عنه السيد
بريجرمان في مصر دفع الكثير من المهاجرين
معظمهم تم اقناعهم بانهم يمكن ان يذهبون
الى منظومه الاتحاد الاوروبي بعد او من
خلال بولندا لكن مستخدمه كادوات بيد روسيا
وتسبب بالكثير من المشكلات في المناطق
الحدوديه اذا هناك الان مخاطر من ان هذا
الوضع سيتكرر في مثل هذا الوضع اي حكومه
ديمقراطيه في بولندا ستعامل بيلاروسيا
كمصدر تهديد لكنني انا سافرق بين هذا
النوع من التهديد عن التهديد الروسي في
حاله روسيا تهديد عسكري مباشر في حاله ظل
روسيا نرى ته ديدات هجينه مختلفه الانواع
بالطبع من خلال
الاعتقالات
حقوق الانسان
ضيفي من مسكسيدمام
ما الذي او ما الذي يجب على مسك ان تفعله
حتى تهدئ من هذه المخاوف لدى جيرانها
اعتقد ان نصف الحقيقه تحاول القيام بما
تستطيع القيام به لتهدئه هذه
المخاوف وقد تكرر ذلك
قبل بضعه ايام عرض على بولندا محادثات
مباشره بما في ذلك بين الاطراف العسكري
وانا اتذكر انه في الماضي كان هناك اطراء
من جانب القادر العسكريين
البولنديين فيما يتعلق بالتواصل لكن بعد
2020 تم فرض نوع من الحصار والعقوبات
الموجوده الان والمقاطعه وتم ايقاف كل
الاتصالات بين الجاذبين على المستوى
العسكري اذا علينا ان لا نحشد القوات على
الحدود بل نتواصل كما عرضه من
مدير مجلس حوار ملعقات الدوليه شكرا لك
وكذلك يا ضيفي من ثياب لوكاش ادامسكي
الخبير البولندي في الشؤون الدوليه
[موسيقى]
يتواصل القتال بين الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع وقال الجيش انه قصف
بالطائرات والمدفعيه مواقع الدعم في
الخرطوم وام درمان من ناحيه اخرى شهدت
مدينه نيالا عاصمه
يوم اخر من ايام القتال المستعر في
السودان بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع ذكر
ان الجيش وفي اطار ما يصفه بحمله تطهير
العاصمه القوميه من كل مواقع الدعم قصف
بالمدفعيه الثقيله مناطق في شرق الخرطوم
ووسط وشرق ام درمان وقال انها بعض من
ارتكازات الدعم السريع الاستراتيجيه بينما
تجددت في ولايه جنوب دارفور الاشتباكات
بين الطرفين في مدينه نيالا عاصمه الولايه
وسقط قتلى وجرحى جراء قص بعض احياء
المدينه وذلك بعد فتره هدوء متقطعه اعقبت
مواجهات عنيفه جرت اخيرا في احياء الوادي
وكرري جنوبي المدينه وبعد ايام من الدمار
الشامل الذي طال احد اسواق نيال الكبيره
في هذه الاثناء وبعد التحذيرات الدوليه من
التداعيات الانسانيه السيئه المتوقعه جراء
النقص الغذائي الحاد في عدد من المواقع
المتاثره بالحرب تحذر السلطات الصحيه
المحليه والدوليه الان من كارثه صحيه
وشيكا بسبب نفاذ الادويه في كل السودان
جراء استمرار القتال وتقول ان المناطق
المتاثره وغير المتاثره تعيش احوالا صحيه
بالغه التعقيد واعلن المجلس القومي
للادويه والسموم بالسودان قائمه بالادويه
غير المتوفره او الوشيكه النفاذ وتحتاج
للامداد العاجل وناشد المجلس مستورد
الادويه الاستجابه العاجله لسد هذا النقص
والتزم بتسهيل عمليات الاستيراد وكانت
مؤسسات صحيه عده قد حذرت من تناقص الادويه
المنقذه للحياه منذ اندلاع القتال في
منتصف شهر ابريل الماضي وت تزايد النداءات
الموجهه للطرفين من مختلف المنظمات
العامله بتسهيل توصيل المساعدات العامه مع
التحذير بامكانيه حدوث الاسوء ما لم يتم
تدارك الامر
وكيف يتم التدارك ذلك هو السؤال الصعب
المطروح في ظل تعثر مختلف الجهود المبذوله
لوقف القتال المستعر بين الجيش والدعم
السريع
[موسيقى]
افتتح السلطات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي جزرا
معلقا للمشاه بلده سلوان جنوب المسجد
الاقصى المبارك ويربط الجسر بين تلتين في
حي وادي الربابه بسلوان وتمت اقامه هذا
الجسر بعد مصادره اراض فلسطينيه وقال
مقديسيون انه يندرج في اطار مشاريع
التهويد وتغيير المشهد العام للمدينه
ما لكن احيانا يصبح الجسر هو العائق اذ
كان من الممكن لهذا الطريق المعلق في
الهواء ان يلامس الشمس فعلا فيضيف على
متعه التجوال مشيا في شوارع القدس متعه
اخرى لكن خلف اقامه هذا الجسر هناك قصه
قصه تخفيها السلطات الاسرائيليه عن السياح
والزائرين تماما كما تفعل لاخفاء جغرافيا
المكان
وتاريخه مشان ابن هذا الجسر في حي وادي
الربابه تمت سرقه اراضينا جميعها تم
السيطره على اراضينا جميعها في حي وادي
الربابه في الواد وفي الجدول وتم زراعه
كروم العنب في اراضينا وممنوع ندخل
اراضينا هون وتم حبسنا وتم سجدنا في فتره
قطف الزيتون
نحو 100 دونم من اراضي الفلسطينيين صدرت
في سلوان لاقامه هذا الجسر واسفله انشئت
هذه المسارات والحدائق التوراتيه اذ
تتعمدوا سلطات الاحتلال اطفاء صبغه اثريه
ونمط بناء قديم وحياه بدائيه على المواقع
السياحيه في ايحاء بعلاقه المكان بتاريخ
يهودي هي عباره عن تزييف للواقع وهو عباره
عن مشروع خطير تهويدي لمنطقه وادي الربابه
كجزء لا يتجزا من القدس الشريف وبالتالي
اصبحت المنطقه تعج بالمستوطنين تعج
بالغرباء وبالتالي وكاننا اصبحنا غرباء في
وطننا
وعلاوه على مساعي تغيير المعادله بين
الغرباء واصحاب الارض فان استقطاب هذا
العدد الكبير من المستوطنين يفاقم من
التضييقات على العائلات الفلسطينيه في
الحيوان
صار الوضع كيف طلع جرافات سيارات مش
كل واحد يطلع على شغله على بيته نص ساعه
بس يستنى كل يوم كل الصبح وبعد الظهر لانه
بفتحوا الجسر هذا من الساعه 6:00 الصبح
على هالموال في سلوان كما في سائر احياء
القدس المحتله يخوض الفلسطيني معركه يوميه
ومستمره من اجل البقاء لكن تشتد المعركه
على سلوان وتزداد وتيره تهويدها
والاستيلاء على بيوت الفلسطينيين وتهجيرهم
منها ولعل في موقعها وتسميتها الحاميه
الجنوبيه للمسجد الاقصى يكمن السر في صمود
سكانها
نجوان سمري الجزيره القدس المحتله
اذا هو اكثر من مجرد جسر مشاه معلق ومعه
يستحضر الحديث عن الحدائق الثوراتيه وهي
مشروع اورشليم حسب الوصف الثوره ووفق
التوصيف الاسرائيلي لجعل محيط البلده
القديمه والاقصر محاطا ومحاصرا بسلسله من
الحدائق والمسارات التلميذيه لنفهم المشهد
اكثر ننظر الى خريطه القدس وها هي كما
نشاهدها في هذه الصوره العلويه وتبرز هنا
البلده القديمه وكذلك المسجد الاقصى كما
نشاهد المشروع يستهدف هذه المناطق كما
ترونها بهذا اللون المختلف تمتد من بلدتي
سلوان
وجبل المكبر جنوبا والعيساويه وجبل
المشارف شمالا وراس العمود وبلده الطور
ومنطقه برك السلطان سليمان ومذيله غربا
كما نشاهد في هذه الخريطه وبات يعرف
المشروع بانه احد اكثر الوسائل التي
يستخدمها الاحتلال لنزع الاراضي من
الفلسطينيين مجمل مساحه هذا المشروع
الاستيطاني ستبلغ نحو
17,500 دونم هذا المشروع بدات فكرته في
العام
1970 سيكلف سلطات الاحتلال الاكثر من
ثمانيه مليارات ونصف المليار دولار يستمر
العمل فيه تنفيذه حتى العام
2030 الحدائق التوراتيه ومشاريع الاستيطان
في القدس يراها كثيرون جزءا من مشروع كبير
يسمى
بالقدس عام 2050 يهدف الى دمج الشرقي
وغربي مدينه القدس بما يضمن عدم تقسيمها
مره اخرى والحيلوله دون تحقيق الرؤيه
الدوليه باعتبار شرقي القدس عاصمه دوله
فلسطين اذا يتم المشروع عبر طريق
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تحيه لك ولمشاهديك
الكرام بدايه الاحتلال يستهدف الهويه
العربيه والاسلاميه في مدينه القدس هناك
مشاريع استيطانيه ومشاريع تهويديه يريد
تغيير التركيب السكانيه لصالح المستوطنين
وايضا تغيير هويه والمشهد العام في هذه
المدينه المقدسه
وتحديدا خنق البلده القديمه والمسجد
الاقصى بمشاريع تهويديه لان الاحتلال يبحث
عن
صياغه جديده للتاريخ ليثبت احقيه وجود
هؤلاء وسيطرتهم على مدينه القدس ولذلك
ويستهدف مدينه القدس يجعلها طارده
للمقدسيين لجلب مزيد من المستوطنين واظن
ان كل هذه المشاريع التي بدات تخطيط فيها
بعد سنوات قليله من احتلال الجزء الشرقي
من القدس تجمع عليها كل حكومات الاحتلال
وحتى كل الاحزاب من اليسار الى اليمين
وتسخر دوله الاحتلال كل امكانيات دوله
الاحتلال لتهويد الجزء الشرقي من القدس
وهذا المشروع الضخم ما يسمى بالحوض
التاريخي المقدس حسب زعمهم او وهو جزء من
مشروع وشريم حسب الوصف التوراتي الذي وقع
عليه نتنياهو شخصيا
لزياده وقعت وزياده سرعه التهويد يعمل على
اولا محاصره البلده القديمه والمسجد
الاقصى طرد السكان عدم اعطاء تراخيص
وللعلم في هذه المنطقه التي هي 17,500
دونم في محيط المسجد الاقصى والبد القديمه
منذ احتلال جزئي الجزء الشرقي من القدس
حتى يومنا هذا لم يعطي الاحتلال ترخيص
واحد
للمقدسيين في الوقت الذي بنى وكبر وسمن
واستولى على راضي لمنازل وممتلكات لصالح
المستوطنين فيريد تغيير التركيب السكانيه
وايضا يريد اقامه مشاريع تهويديه
الادمغه من يصل الى هذه المنطقه ويرى
مسارات المضيئه حدائق توراتيه هو يعمل تحت
الارض لطمس المعالم والاثار
وسلخ هذه المدينه عن ارثى التاريخي العربي
والاسلامي وتجير بعض الاثار لتحاكي روايات
تخدم وجود الاحتلال
واحقيه وجوده كما يزعم وتاريخه
المقدسيون ما الذي يمكن فعله حيال هذا
المشروع
نعم يعني لا يملك المقدسي الا الصمود
والثبات وتحدي سياسات الاحتلال والبقاء في
المناطق التي يستهدفها الاحتلال فمثلا
عندما اراد تغيير وضع القائم في المسجد
الاقصى عام 2017 الثبوت الثبات والصمود
والتحدي الذي ادى الى انكفاء الاحتلال في
المواقع التي يريد الاحتلال تغيير اقامه
جسور اقامه حدائق توراتيه جلب مزيد من
المستوطنين
لوصولهم الى الجزء الشرقي ان يتدافع الناس
اهل القدس وللبقاء والصمود والبقاء في هذه
المناطق واحياء كل مناسباتهم القوميه
والدينيه فيها وايضا حتى يعني تراثنا
العام ايضا المؤسسات الفلسطينيه والعربيه
عليها ان تتحمل مسؤوليتها باستثمارات
بالبناء بايجاد ما يعني يبقي تمكين صمود
وثبات اهل القدس فيها لذلك
نعم يعني اولا القانون الدولي مغيب عن
منطقه القدس لان الاحتلال حتى لا يسمح
لليونسكو
يعني معرفه ما يدور بالانفاق والحفريات
وتحطيم التاريخ والقانون الدولي يمنع
الاحتلال من تغيير واقع هذه المدينه ان
كان على الارض او تحت الارض وحتى في
فضائها ولكن هذا القانون الدولي من يعني
هناك العالم والمجتمع الدولي الذي
ازدواجيه المعايير لا يقوم باي عمل لايقاف
او منع الاحتلال من تغيير واقع واظن ان
الاحتلال يتعدى على القانون الدولي
والمواثيق والمعاهدات الدوليه ولكن صمت
العالم اعطى الاحتلال ضوء اخضر في مزيد من
تغوله على القدس وعروبتها وتاريخها
وماضيها ولذلك لا نملك الا الصمود والثبات
واظن ان هناك كثير من اوراق الضغط التي
يستطيع العالم العربي والاسلامي استعم
الها ولكن للاسف هناك تراخي شكرا لك عدم
جديه ولا توجد نيه حقيقيه في التعامل مع
هذا الموقف من القدس فخري ابو دياب الباحث
الشؤون القدس والناشط المقدس شكرا جزيلا
لك
ختام حصاد هذه الليله الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]